well Santa made a visit to Helen J  Stewart's special school today it's  their annual Santa Day Parade many  sponsors today took part in making it  all happen including CCSD School Police  SWAT the Las Vegas aviators among others  well the school's principal tells us  it's a fun day for those at school to  really celebrate the year-long learning  it's a chance to give our students the  exposure to our community to our  community our community gives back to us  as a school all of our students have  multiple disabilities so this is a  chance for them to celebrate their  learning  looks like a fun day out there all right  well even all Motown gave a special  performance for the students and staff  to get everyone in the holiday spirits